[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع العيال اختيار استهلوها بادرس
العنويه
قتيلان وخمسه جرحى في هجوم بسكين داخل
قطار في المانيا وسلطات تعلن اعتقال
المنفذ
صراع قضائي يهدد التحقيق في انفجار مرفا
بيروت والبيطار للعربيه انا الوحيد المعني
بالتحقيق
النوويه بين الهند
عام 2019
[موسيقى]
بقدر لم يتوقعه حتى اكبر المتفائلين تستعد
اوكرانيا لاستقبال عشرات الدبابات كهدايا
من الغرب منها نحو 80 دبابه من طراز لا
يعبار اثنين الالمانيه وايضا 31 دبابات
ابرامز سترسلها واشنطن كما اكد بيدن
وبالتالي ولاول مره منذ الحرب العالميه
ستواجه الدبابات الروسيه دبابات اخرى
غربيه على الاراضي الاوكرانيه الفراشه
يعول عليها الاوكرانيون لتغيير مجرى الحرب
لصالحهم اما روسيا التي هددت بتدبير تلك
الدبابات في اعلن رئيسها انه يدرس الرد
عسكريا على هذا الدعم الغربي لكاس
تضايق عمل ناصر 30
دبابه ابرامز لاوكرانيا الامر الذي يكون
كتيبه اوكرانيا الوزير اوستن صاحب الخطوه
لانها تعزز قدره اوكرانيا على الدفاع عن
اراضيها وتحقيق الاهداف الاستراتيجيه
دبابات ابرامز هي الاقوى في العالم ومعقده
في التشغيل لذا سنمنح اوكرانيا قطع الغيار
والادوات التي تسمح بابقاء الدبابات عامله
في ميدان المعركه سنبدا بتدريب القوات
الاوكرانيه على تشغيلها في اسرع وقت ممكن
توصيل هذه الدبابات للمعركه سيحتاج وقتا
هذا الوقت سنستخدمه في التاكد من ان
الاوكرانيين قادرون على دمج دبابات ابرامز
في جيشهام
مشاهدينا للحديث اكثر عن هذه التطورات
ينضم الينا من واشنطن بير غانم مراسل
العربيه وايضا من موسكو عبد الجواد الرشد
مراسل العربيه سابدا معك ابيار يعني هذا
الدعم السياسي العسكري اليوم الذي قدمته
الولايات المتحده الاكياز ماذا يعني بهذا
التوقيت بالذات من الحرب وكل التفاصيل
المحيطه بهم
نبدا اولا بملاحظه اساسيه يجب التوقف
عندها هو انه خلال البيان الذي ادلى به
الرئيس قال ان هذا الدعم لاوكرانيا لا
يعني على الاطلاق تهديد لامن همم روسيا ثم
تحدث الرئيس الامريكي بشكل مفصل على ان
الدول الغربيه الداعمه لاوكرانيا تقف صفا
واحدا في اعطائها ما تحتاجه لتحرير
اراضيها ما نشهده الان هو اولا اعطاء
الاوكرانيين ما يحتاجونه
لبدء تحرير المزيد من الاراضي التي
احتلتها القوات الروسيه منذ عام وحتى
اليوم ومن جهه اخرى نرى ان هناك طراز في
الصفوف الغربيه واصرار على مساعده
الاوكرانيين في هذه العمليه العسكريه
اسمح لي بيار ان انتقل الى عبد الجواد
لنقل الصوره من موسكو بعد ما اعلن الرئيس
الروسي الرد على هذه على هذا الدعم الغربي
وتحديدا بالدبابات لاوكرانيا عبد الجواد
هل ما المتوقع بهذا الرد الروسي
تتحدث عن ان قرار برلين بمنح اوكرانيا
الدبابات الغربيه كما تسميها موسكو بانه
قرار تصعيد خطير وقد ينتقل بعمليه الصراع
الى مرحله شديده خلال المواجهات هذا ما
تحدثت عنه سفاره موسكو لدابيرلين ولد
واشنطن وما تحدثت عنه الخارجيه هو
والكرملين لذلك نلاحظ بان الاوراق
السياسيه في البلاد اليوم تتحدث عن
المرحله القادمه التي قد تدفع موسكو من
خلالها بعدد كبير من الدبابات على ما يبدو
الحديث يدور عند دبابات ارماتا من طراز في
90 او الدبابات التي تحدثت عنها موسكو
اليوم والتي لم تشارك في السابق في
العمليه العسكريه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وهي من تراثيه 80 هي دبابات من العيار
الثقيل تتمتع طبعا بخاصيه للحمايه وسط
الضربات وت طبعا قذائف يسميها البعض
بالقسيه والقاتله حتى هذه اللحظه ما زالت
موسكو تطمئن عبر وزاره دفاعا بان الدبابات
الغربيه ان وصلت الى الاراضي الاوكرانيه
ان كانت امريكيه الصنع او كانت المانيه او
من جهه اخرى ستعمل موسكو على تدميرها كما
قالت متري بسكوف اليوم سيتم حرق هذه
الدبابات بشكل كامل لكن طبعا ما وصفه بان
هذه الدبابات هي يعني لديها ثمن اغلى في
السوق وطبعا كما وصفهم بدافعوا الضرائب
الغربيين ويقصد هنا طبعا همم يعني
الحكومات في
القاره الاوروبيه قالوا قال بانهم سيدفعون
ثمن هذه الخطوه بشكل كبير هو تصعيد خطير
تراه موسكو الجميع يتحدث عن هذا الموضوع
ان كان على الصعيد الشعبي او على الصعيد
الرسمي
مجددا الى
همم يعني تحدث يعني المصادر الرسميه عن
اشهر لنقل هذه الدبابات كيف سيتم نقل هذه
الدبابات اذا كان هناك من معطيات عمليات
التدريب كل ما يحيط بهذه عمليه الدعم
العسكريا
مسؤولون امريكيون تحدثوا الى الصحفيين
تمهيدا لبيان الذي ادلى به الرئيس وقالوا
ان ااه عمليات التدريب سوف تاخذ وقتا
ولكنهما رفضوا اعطاء المزيد من التفاصيل
حول المكان وحول كيف سوف يتم نقل هذه
الدبابات من اراضي الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه او من الاماكن في اوروبا باتجاه
الاراضي الاوكرانيه من الضروري الاشاره
الى ان هذه الدبابات الامريكيه ربما لا
تفيد الاوكرانيين في هذه المعركه بقدر ما
ان الاعلان الامريكي هو تاكيد على التضامن
بين الامريكيين والا اوروبيين في دعم
الاوكرانيين في اشاره اخرى مهمه الى هذا
الدعم السياسي والامني والعسكري هو ان
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي يجتمع منذ
يوم امس في العاصمه الامريكيه مع نظرائه
من عده دول اوروبيه وخصوصا من المانيا
وفرنسا وبريطانيا وهم ينظرون الى امكانيات
المساعده لاوكرانيا ايضا تهديدات التي
يدلي بها الروس ردا على هذه المساعدات
الامريكيه والاوروبيه والاكرانيين وكيف
سوف تكون المرحله المقبله بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا وايضا بالنسبه للمتحالفين
الغربيين شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]
حرب دبابات طرحها الوضع الحالي في
اوكرانيا تستعرض فيها اطراف القتال
والاطراف الدوليه قدرتها العسكريه وتراهن
بها على المكاسب على الارض الجيش الروسي
ثاني اقوى جيوش العالم حسب مؤشر القوه
العسكريه وليث معظمه ترسانته من الدبابات
من الاتحاد السوفيتي لتصيله رساماته من
الدبابات القتاليه الاساسيه فقط الى نحو
ثلاثه الاف مئه دبابه في الخدمه واحد
10,400 دبابه احتياطيه
تشارك الانواع الابرز منها في الحرب على
اوكرانيا
سي 702 دخلت الخدمه عام
1973 المدفع الرئيسي 125 ملم املس
[موسيقى]
قوه المحرك 780 حصان السرعه القصوى للطريق
60 كيلو مترا في الساعه المدى 500 كيلو
متر
في اي تي دخلت الخدمه عام
المدفع الرئيسي 125 متر املس محرك
قوه المحرك 1000 حصان
الطريق 70 كيلو متر في الساعه المدى
335 كلم
عام
1993 المدفع الرئيسي 125 متر املس يحرك
ديزل قوه المحرك 840 حصان السرعه القصوى
للطريق 60 كلم في الساعه المدى 550 كلم
الا انا احدث الدبابات الروسيه وفخر
الصناعتها هي ارماتا التي لم تدخل الخدمه
بعد وتزعم موسكو انها تتفوق على دبابه
ابرامز الامريكيه كونها تندمج بشكل اكبر
ضمن شبكه معلومات واحده تربط مختلفه
الاسلحه كما ان طاقمها يكون محمدا داخل
كبسوله مدرعه منفصله عن حموله الذخيره الى
عمر العربيه
من جانبه كان المستشار الالماني والفوز قد
اعلن بشكل رسمي امام البرلمان ان المانيا
ستقدم دبابات اليو فارس اثنين الى
اوكرانيا بهدف الدفاع عن نفسها وقال انا
ستدرب القوات الاوكرانيه على استخدام
الدبابات وصياماتها
فيديو سبايدر مان
مع الولايات المتحده بتقديم مركبات برادلي
وستقدم المانيا وفرنسا المزيد من
المساعدات سنقدم 6 دبابات اليوبارد 2
وستكون من مخزوننا وسندرب المهندسين على
صيانه الدبابات
ان هذا القرار الالماني الذي اتى بعد
التشاور مع شركاء وحلفاء الناتو ياتي في
فتره نصيبه في الحرب في اوكرانيا ومن شانه
ان يساعدك في الدفاع عن نفسها
قبل ذلك مشاهدينا دعا رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني للشيخ سوناكدول غربيه الى تعزيز
دعمها العسكري الى اوكرانيا كما اكد
الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي ان دبابات
ابرامز الامريكيه و تشالنجر البريطانيه
وليوبار الالمانيه ستمكن اوكرانيا من
الانتصار كما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الفرنسيه
انها سترسل اول مركبه مدرعه من طراز اي ام
اكس 10 الى اوكرانيا في شهر فبراير ايضا
اعلنت النرويج انها سترسل دبابات من
مخزنها في اوكرانيا الى اوكرانيا وافادت
وسائل الاعلام الالمانيه
لارسالتي دبابات الى اوكرانيا تتكون من 80
الى 100 دبابه كما اعلنت سلوفاكيا انها
سترسل 30 دبابه من طراز تي 72 صوفيا الى
اوكرانيا كما ستناقش نقل مقاتلات ام اي جي
[موسيقى]
بالتسامح مع الاعلانات الغربيه حول ارسال
دبابات
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي فيديو تظهر
دبابات بالقرب من العاصمه الفرلنديه وسط
المحاكم بتجهيزها لشحنها الى اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اذا قرار الدول الغربيه وعلى راسها واشنطن
وبرين بارسال دبابات قتال متطوره ليست
العقده الوحيده التي كانت تواجدك الخطوه
الاصعب تتمثل بكيفيه نقل هذه المركبات
المدرعه الثقيله الى كياف وافقه صحيفه
شحنه معظم الاسلحه في الدبابات سيتم اما
على عربات سكك حديديه او شاحنات مسطحه
قويه بما يكفي لتحمل وزن هذه الدبابات
لكنها سكك الحديديه عموما هي الطريقه
الاسرع والاكثر امانا لنقل المعدات نظرا
لان القوافل الطويله من الشاحنات المسطحه
ستجذب انتباه روسيا هذا ان تم غض النظر عن
المشاكل التي تواجهها سكك الحديد
الاوكرانيه حاليا وتتمثل المخاوف مشاهدينا
ايضا استهداف الروسيه للطرق او اماكن
انطلاق المعدات اثناء الشحنها الى الخطوط
الاماميه في وجنوب اوكرانيا كما ان قياده
الدبابات والعربات المدرعه الاخرى الى
ساحه المعركه سيستغرق المزيد من الوقت
والوقود وقطع الغيار وقد تصبح هدفا متحركه
لطائرات الروسيه وتعد عمليه تسليم الاسلحه
الغربيه والمعدات العسكريه الاخرى الى
اوكرانيا واحده من اكبر اسرار الحرب
حراساتها مشدده وعاد ما تكون متخفيه في
ظلام لتفادي الهجوم عليها
[تصفيق]
تصاعد خلاف غربي داخلي وتصاعدي توتر
الاوروبيين
روسيت ذات الامكانات العسكريه الفائقه
تتوق اوكرانيا لاشراجها في ساحه المعركه
المحتدمه مع روسيا ولكن ما الذي يجعلها في
بؤره ضوء ساحه المعركه الروسيه الاوكرانيه
وفقا لقائد كتيبه دبابات امريكي نقل عنه
موقع
1945 فان الدبابات الالمانيه تتمتع بتطور
انظمه الرؤيه والاستهداف النهاري والليلي
مقارنه بدبابات برادلي الامريكيه التي
اعتدى عليها القائد كما يتمتع المدفع
الرئيسي لليوبارد بثبات كبيره وقدره فائقه
على ضرب الاهداف هذا بالاضافه الى
امتلاكها دروعا اماميه قادره على مواجهه
نظيرتها روسيه الى جانب نقاء انظمه
الاتصال الداخلي بين افراد كتيبه اليوبار
الاثنين
قدره قتاليه واخرى فنيه تتمتع بها ليوبارد
اثنان فلديها سرعه فائقه في تزويد
محركاتها التي تعمل بالديزل الى جانب ندره
تعرضها لاعطال الميكانيكيه ثم سهوله نقلها
من الدول المجاوره والدعامه في شرق اوروبا
لكنها تواجه تحديات لتحقيق الهدف من
وجودها في ساحه المعركه ابرزها استجابه
الجنود الاوكرانيين لعمليات التدريب عليها
من قبل الخبرات العسكريه الغربيه
ووافقا للقائد العسكري الامريكي تواجه
اليوبارد تحديا اخر وهو الاصعب يتمثل في
مدى قدرتها على الصمود في وجه المسارات
الروسيه
وبقدر ما تحتاج اوكرانيا لليوبارد اثنين
الالمانيه تحتاج ايضا للاستعداد على رده
فعل روسيه تاقلمت وتكيفت مع امدادات
عسكريه غربيه سابقه وضلت تجد مخرجا
لاستمرار مواجهه عسكريه عنيده
علي السمان العربيه
بالمراحل السابقه كل مرحله من هذه الحرب
كان لها عنوان لعل العنوان الاساسي اليوم
هي حرب الدبابات كيف يمكن لهذه الدفعه من
الدبابات ان تغير بموازين القوى على الارض
وخصوصا في الشرق
ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
المزيد من الهجمات المضاده والمناوره نعلم
مدى اهميه هذه الدبابات للجيش الاوكراني
وكيف كان لها دورا كبيرا في تحرير الكويت
وفي العراق اذنها لاعبه دورا جوهريا في
العمليات الهجوميه التي جنت في هذه
المعارك كذلك راينا اهميه الدبابات في
الحرب التي دارت بين اسرائيل ومصر في
سبعنيات القرن الماضي حيث كان الجيش
المصري يستخدمه الدبابات من اجل من اجل
كسر خطوط الدفاع الموجوده عبر قناه السويس
وتطويقي المنطقه لدى يمكن لهذه الدبابات
ان تحقق
مكاسبه على الارض سري لكن لابد من استخدام
ايهاب بصوره متوازيه مع القوه الجويه ومع
القوات الاخرى
يقال عن هذه الدبابات بان اول دخول
لدبابات غربيه بوجه الدبابات سوفيتيه منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه بالحرب العالميه
الثانيه عندما حشر الروس طوروا دبابه عرفت
باستعلام على اسم الزعيم السوفيتي اليوم
هل ممكن ان تذهب روسيا الى تطوير نوعه
جديد من الدبابات بوجه هذه الدبابات
الغربيه
ياسمين
تطويرها ابانا الحرب البارده في ثمانينات
القرن الماضي
وكانت قد صممت على وجه التحديد من اجل
الدبابات التي تمتلكها القوات السوفيتي
القوات الروسيه وهي ما وردتها من العهد
السوري
روسيا
قامت بتطوير دبابات من اجل مضاهات الغرب
لكن حتى اللحظه لم يستطيعوا الا انتاج هذه
الدبابات المضاهيه لنظيرتها الغربيه الا
باعداد المحدوده
ولهذا السبب لم نراها تستخدم الكثير منها
في حرب اوكرانيا لانها لا هو تبدو خسارتها
بسرعه لذا احسبه
ان هذه الدبابات التي سوف يقدمها
تقدمها الدول الغربيه
سوف يكون لها دور فعال لكن روسيا التي
تمتلك عدد اكبر من الدبابات التي سوف تحصل
عليها اخرى ولا اعلم اذا كان ميزان القوه
سوف يغير بين جوده الدبابات الموجوده لدى
اوكرانيا من جهه وبين كميه الدبابات
الكثيره الموجوده لدى روسيا من جهه اخرى
شكرا
للسياسه العسكري في معهد هارون
ردا على تصليح الغربي لك اياه فاعلن موسكو
بدات تدريبات على استخدام الصواريخ الاسرع
من الصوت في مناطق الجزء الغربي من المحيط
الاطلسي وهذه الصواريخ بامكانها التحليق
لمسافه تصل الى احد 10,000 كم في الساعه
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
لم تنتهي وانما الاستراتيجيه تغيرت مؤقتا
وشطاء ايرانيون ينسون انخمد الاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نقلت وكاله الانباء
الالمانيه عن مسؤول حكوميه قوله ان رجلا
طعن سبعه اشخاص في قطار كان متجها من
مدينه كيل الى هامبرغر ما ادى الى مقتل
الحسين واصابه الخمسه الاخرين من جهتها
اعلنت الشرطه الالمانيه توقيف المنفذ
[موسيقى]
ازمه وعداله تواجهها قضيه انفجار مرفق
بيروت طرفاها للان قد التحقيق طارق
البيطار والمدعى العام التمييزي غسان
البيطار في تصريح للعربيه شدد على انه هو
المحقق العدلي الوحيد في القضيه وهو فقط
من يحق له اطلاق سراح الموقفين بقضيه
تفجير المعرفه موجها لاتهامه للنائب العام
التمييزي غسان عويداد ومشيرا الى انه ليس
مخولا بان ياخذ اي قرار بقضيه بيروت وشدد
البيطار على ان تحقق العدليه الوحيد في
القضيه وانه هو فقط من يحق له اطلاق سراح
الموقوفين بقضيه مرفا بيروت موجه عن
الاتهامات كغسان عويدات مضيفا انه غير
مخول باتخاذ القرارات بقضيه المرفق وكما
كان متوقعا ساندت ميليشيا حزب الله النائب
العام التمييزي وايد قرار الاخير بالافراج
عن كافه المتهمين بقضيه تفجير مرفا بيروت
وفي لبنان ايضا مشاهدينا احتجاجات متزامنه
ومتشابهه شكلا ومضمونا يشهدها شرعا
اللبناني والعراق عمله محليه متدهوره
وغلاء بالاسعار حيث تجمع العراقيون اليوم
امام البنك المركزي للاحتجاج ضد انخفاضات
الدينار العراقي مقابل الدولار تراجع
الدينار اطاعها سريعا بمحافظه المركزي اما
سبب ما وصف بجنون الدولار فهو تهريب
الدولارات من العراق الى ايران والمقدره
بنحو مئه مليون دولار شهريا حسب روترس
علما بان تراجع قيمه الدينار امام
الدولارتها عند
160 دينار للدولار الواحد وهو رقم لم
يسجله العراق منذ 19 عاما المشهد في لبنان
مشاهدينا لم يختلف كثيرا حيث احتج العشرات
امام البنك المركزي على خلفيه تردد
الاوضاع المعيشيه وارتفاع اسعار المحروقات
حرق اطارات واغلاق طرقات اساسيه في مناطق
مختلفه
اصلا انتشار مكثف للجيش فالليره اللبنانيه
تواصل انهيارها امام الدولار الغير
المسبوق ملامسه عتبه عتبه 56,000 ليره
مقابل الدولار في السوق السوداء هذا
واغلقت محطات البنزين ابوابها على ان
تعاود عملها بعد صدور جدول جديد للاسعار
من وزاره الطاقه
خلال اسبوع واحد ارتفعت كل الاسعار في
لبنان بشكل هستيري مع تسجيل سعر صرف
الدولار رقما قياسيا جديدا وهو 56,000
ليره لبنانيه جنون الاسعار هذا انعكس هذه
طبيعه الحال على اسعار المحروقات لتتخطى
المليون ليره ثمنها الصحيحه
فوق المليون خلص
[موسيقى]
للاسف يعني
وهو صغير لاي خطوط انقاذيه واصلاحيه افلس
اللبنانيون من حلول الكفاح المعيشي ليعود
الشارع مقصدهم الى مصر في لبنان الوجهه
الاساسيه للمتظاهرين عند كل استحقاق ملي
حضر عدد من المواطنين وقطعوا الطريق
احتجاجا وبعد حوالي ساعتين غادروا انشغالا
بهمومهم اليوميه من تبعات الازمه اسباب
انهيار العمله كثيره وطالب هذه الاسباب
موجوده فلا سقفه للانهيار
رئيس جمهوريه ما فيه حكومه وبرلمان عاجزين
بنك مركزي ومصارف ما عندهم احتياطات
اجنبيه قضاء
معطل او عاجز كمان او منقسم بدليل قصه
انفجار المرفق كلها العوامل كابيتال
كونترول
منقرضت واتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي كمان
منقر ومتى منع شراء الدولارات من لبنان
الى سوريا
المستشار المالي لحزب الله حسن مقلد الذي
ادرج ضمن العقوبات الامريكيه مؤخرا لاعبه
دوره في هذا الانهيار
حسن مقلد يا اللي بتقول وزاره الخزانه انه
عندها همم مش اكتبها فيها بنشاط مالي
بتسهل نشاط مالي لحزب الله وخصوصا اليوم
كمان في معلومات بتقول انه صار عم بلم
دولارات من السوق
الليره
الشرائيه وغلائي كافه السلع والخدمات من
تبيعات الازمه ولا حله بحسب المراقبين الا
بانجاز الاتفاقي مع صندوق النقد الدولي
ناهد يوسف العربيه بيروت
[موسيقى]
الى العراق حيث اعلنت وزاره الداخليه
العراقيه ان وكاله الاستخبارات احبطت
مخططا لتنظيم داعش لاستهداف محكمه استئناف
نينوى شمال البلاد بهجوم الانتحاري وقالت
وزاره الداخليه في بيان ان الهجوم كنا
سينفذه ثلاثه انتحاريين وظيفه انه جرى
لقاء القبض على العناصر الثلاثه مع
اسلحتهم ومعداتهم قبل دخولهم المحكمه
وتنفيذي مخططها
وفي سوريا اعلنت قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
قصد اطلاق عمليات عسكريه واسعه النطاق ضد
خلايا تنظيم داعش في الرقه سرحت قصد في
بيانها ان العمليات الامنيه
من الولايات المتحده او من التحالف الدولي
وحققت نتائج فوريه وحاسمه
[موسيقى]
مقدارنا المظاهرات في ايران لزخمها
المعتاد او انخمادها وصفا يرفضه
الايرانيون الذين يؤكدون ان احتجاجاتهم ضد
النظام لم تهدا او تصمت واوضح متظاهرون ان
المتغير الوحيد هو استراتيجيات التجمع
والتحرك فقط لاسباب عده اولها اساليب
القمع المتزايده من الاجهزه الامنيه
بالاضافه طبعا لظروف الجويه القاسيه
وانشغال الايرانيين بالفتره الماضيه بازمه
نقص الغاز والوقود لكن العجوز عن تامين
التدفئه والخبز وما شابه يزيد النقد
الشعبيه والتظاهرات التي دخلت مرحله جديده
مظاهرات ليليه محدوده مع كتابه الشعارات
على الشجره ووفقه ايران انترناشونال كتابه
الشعارات المناهضه للنظام تتوسع بشكل
ملحوظ خصوصا في مشهد في مدينه مشهد وسط
جهود من السلطات لمحوها قبل الانتشار فيما
الشعرات تتردد ايلان حتى من نوافذ المنازل
في العاصمه طهران ومناطق محيطه بينها
نارماك وايضا مدن اخرى بالتوازي طبعا مع
حرق صور رموز النظام ومهاجمه مقر البسيج
مشاهدينا تشير التقارير هنا تقارير جديده
الى استمرار الاعتقالات التعسفيه وتعذيب
السجناء والضغط على عائلاتهم من بين هذه
العائلات ومن بينهم المواطن محسن تهمه
ثابت الذي اعتقل في نوفمبر كما يواصل
القضاء الايراني ممارسه الضغط على السجناء
المعرضين لخطر الاعدام باللجوء الى تهمه
الافساد
[موسيقى]
في خبر
بريطانيا الى تقديمي اجابات حول اعدام
ودفن المواطن البريطانيه الايراني علي رضا
اكبر
ان الحكومه الايرانيه تتجاهل كرامه
الانسان هذا وكانت ايران اعلنت في الحادي
عشر من الشهر الجاري التنفيذ حكم الاعدام
بحق اقبل بعد اتهامه بالتجسس لصالح
بريطانيا
التاسعه المستمره فيها بعد قليل
عبر الرقائق المدمجه في الالكترونيات
تحذير بريطاني من تجسس الصين على المملكه
المتحده
[موسيقى]
حصان صني محتمل حذر مسؤول بريطانيون من
خلقه للامن القومي وفق صحيفه تلغراف واوضح
ان التهديد المحتمل يتعدى المكونات
الصينيه التي تصنع في ابراج الهاتف
المحمول والتي ادت سابقا لحظر منتجات
هواوي فبريطانيا قليقه من قدره الصين على
التجسس على ملايين البريطانيين عبر تسريحه
الرقائق الدقيقه المدمجه في اجهزتها
الالكترونيه
هذه المهمه تتم عبر ما يعرف بانترنت
الاشياء وهي وحدات صغيره لا يتعدى حجمها
خمسه سنتيمترات تستخدم في كل شيء من
الاجهزه المنزليه وثلاثه ذكيه الى
المصابيح والكاميرات الامنيه والسيارات
وانظمه الاسلحه المتقدمه وطبعا غيرها من
المنتجات تراقب الاستخدام وتنقل البيانات
مره اخرى الى المالك وغالبا الى الشركه
المصنعه عبر بركات 5 جي علما بان ثلاث
شركات صينيه بينها موبايل شاينا تمتلك
بالفعل
54% من السوق العالميه في الاجهزه وعليها
كجميع الشركات الصينيه تسليم البيانات
للحكومه الصينيه اذا طلب من ذلك وقد فكت
مشاهدينا الاجهزه الامنيه لبريطانيه في
وقت سابق هذا الشهر سيارات وزاريه وعثرت
على جهاز واحد على الاقل مخبا داخل مكون
اخر ما زاد طبعا المخاوف من قدره الصين
على مراقبه تحركات الاهداف الاستخباراتيه
من اشخاص واسلحه وامدادات وبمقدمتها
مبيعات الاسلحه الامريكيه لتايوان
امكانيات التجسس هائله لكن المخاوف
تتعداها الى امكانيه تجديد عملاء عبر
ابتزازهم وكذلك التخريب ومهاجمه البنيه
التحتيه من خلال تعطيل الاجهزه وفقا طبعا
للتحذيرات لبريطاني
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر عن هذا الملف ينضم الينا من
لندن مصطفى زارو مرافق العربيه مصطفى يعني
اذا تابعنا التقارير الماضيه هي ليست
المره الاولى التي يبدا بها البريطانيين
الخوف من التجسس الصيني عبر المنتجات ما
تحدثنا عنه بالتقرير وعبر المنتجات
الالكترونيه
الحديثه اليوم ما الجديد بهذا الموضوع ولا
الى اي مدى ممكن ان يؤدي الى ازمه مع
اجانب الصيني
حقيقه ان هذا التقرير هو يضاف الى سلسله
تقارير اخرى حدثت من
استخدام الاجهزه الالكترونيه
الصينيه الصنع هذا يضاف بالطبع الى
اعلنت عنه الحكومه سابقا بانها ستحضر
المنتجات هو واي خصوصا في شبكه الجيل
الخامس هذا بالطبع بعد ان ضغطت الاداره
الامريكيه في صيف 2020 تحت قياده همم
دونالد ترامب بان تحضر المملكه المتحده كل
ما يتعلق بالجيل الخامس
وخاصه لهواوي همم ولكن بالطبع الصين
انتقدت هذه همم هذه الاجراءات وقلب بانها
مسيسه بطبع الحكومه واخر تقرير ايضا اخر
تقرير يعني برلماني حضر من تنامي همم يعني
تنامي يعني الصين واقتصادها
ضخم وقال يجب ان تعتمد المملكه المتحده
على بلدان اخرى في اقتصادها وبتالي حتى
يكون لها قدره على مناوره وايضا يعني همم
القيام ب- ب- يعني الرد على عدوان او
انتهاكات همم تقوم بها بكين هذا بالاضافه
الى ان هذه التقرير البرلماني يقول بانه
في الوقت ال- ال- يعني في الوقت الحالي
يجب التعامل مع الصين كشريك ولكن يجب
التعامل في وقت ما يجب وقف كل هذه همم
التعاملات
التعاملات المتعلقه بالصين وخاصه في ما
يتعلق بالاجزال الالكترونيه همم مصطفى
يعني من المعلوم بان الصين هي اكبر سوق
واكبر مصنع للانترنت الاشياء باسيا
والمحيط الهادئ وايضا من المعلوم بان
الازمه اليوم والحرب التي ترغي بظلالها
على المملكه المتحده وكل اوروبا تجعل من
يعني الاكتفاء الذاتي او الصناعه الداخليه
تتراجع كثيرا وبالتالي اعتماد اكبر على
الصين هل من اي خطه مستقبليه
لتفادي هذا الاعتماد المطلق غير تنويع
الاستيراد
يعني حقيقه هذا ما تطالب به اللجنه
البرلمانيه ولكن هذا قد يتطلب بعض الوقت
يعني مثلا بالنسبه لمنتجات هواوي عندما
اعلن الحكومه عن حظرها كل هذه المنتجات
اعطت مده سبع سنوات يعني بحلول 2027 يجب
التخلص من كل هذه الاجهزه المتعلقه به وهو
في شبكه في شبكه الجيل الخامس لكن هذا
الحذر لا يشمل الجيل الرابع
وهناك بدائل خاصه فيما يتعلق بالمنتجات
الامريكيه وايضا كان هناك حديث عن شركه
نوكيا التي يمكن ان يعني ان يعني يتم
توظيف اجهزتها في الجيل الخامس وخاصه وان
يعني هذا التحدير ليش يشمل فقط المملكه
المتحده بل ايضا همم الدول همم الدول
الغربيه الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
بشكل عام وبالتالي هناك تنسيق بين مختلف
الدول خاصه مع التنامي يعني ال- ال-
العملاق الصيني في السنوات القليله
الماضيه وايضا عندما حذر رئيس الاستخبارات
همم
مقاله همم جهاز الاستخبارات الداخليه قال
بان الصين تشكل تهديدا
كبيرالمتحده وكان في في ندوه مشتركه لاول
مره مع نظيره مدير مكتب التحقيقات
الامريكي وبالتالي هذا غير مسبوق وبالتالي
هناك مسائل الان لمحاوله الحد من التعامل
مع المنتجات التي يمكن ان تستخدمها الصين
للتجسس واستغلالها لتكون لها همم تكون في
ما يتعلق كل ما يتعلق همم التجاره وخاصه
الاجهزه الالكترونيه
[موسيقى]
ازمه العثور على وثائق سريه بحوثات الرئيس
ترامب وراي سبايدر ونائب الرئيس ستطرح
قضيه صلاحياتهم للترشح للانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه فاستطلاعات الرئيسيه ان
البيت الابيض لم يتمتع بالشفافه بينما
يلاحق الاعلام الرئيس ترامب بعد مداهمه
عناصر الاف بي اي لمنزله في فلوريدا ناديه
البلبيسي والتفاصيل
تمام
[تصفيق]
الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه عام 2420
القاسم المشترك ان الثلاثه تحتفظوا بوثائق
صنفت بالسريه امر فتح باب النقاش حول
كفائاتهم لقياده دفه البلاد وحكم الدوله
العظمى في العالم
اذا فعل نفس الشيء وان قادتنا لديه مجموعه
مختلفه من القواعد عن الشخص العادي
الرئيس
لم يكن على علم بتلك الوثائق وان البيت
الابيض تعاون مع وزاره العدل وسلم الوثائق
20 بمجرد العثور عليها بينما ترم راى ان
ملاحقه سياسيه نسجت خطوطها في وزاره العدل
وصلت الى حد مداهمه منتجعه ومصادره مئات
الوثائق بينما نائب الرئيس السابق
اعلن عن تسليم الوثائق للمحفوظات الوطنيه
لكننا فقدان الشفافيه والمصداقيه والتستر
والاهمال اتهامات تلاحق الثلاثه بينما ترم
يواجه تحقيق القضائيا رسميا قد يؤدي الى
تجربه
انفسهم في مواجهه قانونيه وحتى ان تم
اتهامهم بارتكاب جريمه هذا لا يمنع
قانونيا اي شخص من الترشح المنصب بموجب
القانون الامريكي لدافع ان المشكله ليست
قانونيه بل سياسيه لكن يبدو ان استطلاعات
الراي تشير الى ان الامريكيين عموما يرون
الفرق بين وضع ترامب ووضع بايدينا الان
اعتقد ان وضع بايضا ووضع بينس متشابهه
لجدا
ازمه الوثائق الستلاحق بيضا وترامب
عندما يعلن الترشح رسميا
وستسمح لمرشحين اخرين بالنيل من مصداقيتهم
حتى لو نجوا من ملاحقه قضائيه
ممثلوا الرؤساء السابقين كلينتون جورج بوش
الاب والابن والرئيس اوباما قالوا بانهم
قاموا بتسليم كل الوثائق السريه التي كانت
بحوزتهم الى مكتب السجلات الوطنيه والرئيس
كارتر قال بانه لا يملك اي من الوثائق
السريه
الان يبحث في اليه لمنع الرؤساء والوزراء
السابقين من الاحتفاظ بوثائق قد تضر
بالامن الوطني
بمكالمه هاتفيه مفاجاه بمنتصف الليل منعت
واشنطن اندلاع حرب نوويه بين الهند
وباكستان في عام 2019 وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه السابق بوب بيو قال في كتاب
مذكراته ان الهند وباكستان اقتربتا من حرب
النوويه في فبراير عام 2019 وان تدخل
الولايات المتحده منع التصعيد هذه الحادثه
كانت عندما شنت الهند غرام جويه داخل
الاراضي الباكستانيه بعد ان القت باللون
على جماعه مسلحه هناك بتنفيذ تفجير
انتحاري اسفر عن مقتل 41 جنديا هنديا في
كشمير بدورها اسقطت باكستان طائره هنديه
واثرت الطياره رحيلها وقال بومبيو الذي
كان همم موجود لحضور قمه بين الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب و زعيم كوريا
الشماليه كيم جون انه استيقظ على مكالمه
عاجله من مسؤول هندي وكتب
انه المسؤول الهندي وكتاب ايضا انه
المسؤول الهنديه يعتقد بان الباكستانيين
بداوا في اعداد اسلحتهم النوويه لتنفيذ
ضربه
وان الهند تفكر في تصعيدها والرد سريعا
قبل ان تتخذ باكستان الخطوات واشار بومبيو
في كتاب مذكره بانه طلب من المسؤوله
الهنديه الا يفعل شيئا ويمنحهم مقتا لبحث
الامور كاشفا ان الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين
اقنعه الهند وباكستان حينها بان اي منهم
لن يستعد لاستخدام الاسلحه النوويه واعتبر
انه لم يكن بوسع اي دوله اخرى ان تفعل ما
فعلته للولايات المتحده المتمثله طبعا
باداره الرئيس
في تلك الليله لتجنب نتيجه مروعه على
العالم كله وليس على الهند وباكستان فقط
وفقا طبعا لكم ومذكره
[موسيقى]
نستكمل ادم مشاهدينا من الولايات المتحده
وعلى الفوري
في وجه المصارعين الديمقراطيين داخل مجلس
النواب الامريكي
قال رسميا النائبين ديمقراطيين
وايضا من لجنه المخابرات بمجلس النواب
خطوه اثاره الجدل عرضها حتى بعض اعضاء
كتله مكرسي وتصعيد صارخ للمعامله المستمره
ما عنديوقراطيين بشان لكن رئيس المجلس
الجديد يبدو انه كان لديه اسبابه وهو
الانتقام اذ توعد بالانتقام بعد تصويت
الديمقراطيين وبعض الجمهوريين على تصويت
الخطوه مماثله وهو عزل فلسطين
مشاهدينا ننتقل الى واشنطن وهذا المؤتمر
الصحفي للبيت الابيض الابيض
هذه الدبابات المتطوره
مع اوكرانيا
اليوم عن حجم المساعدات التي سوف تزودها
الولايات المتحده
هل سوف
التكنولوجيا الروسيه من خلال تقديم هذه
الدبابات
هذا سوف يكون واقع الحال بالنسبه للانظمه
الاخرى التي قدمناها لاوكرانيا سابقا
للحديث عن اي مؤشرات من مؤشرات الفساد مع
ذلك لابد من الاشاره
تقدموا الى اوكرانيا يجب ان يتم تخزينها
وصيانتها بصيره صحيحه
اذا ما كان هناك اي مخاطر اساسيه
على مساله محاسبه اوكرانيا
من خلال المكاتب
المعنيه اللي في اوكرانيا من اجل ضمان
المحاسبه
في اي وقت يحدث في هذا الامر لكن تذكروا
انها حرب وكل شيء فيها متوقع
لماذا يتم اخراج الدبابات ابرامز من
المخزونات الامريكيه لا تعتقدون ان
الولايات المتحده بحجه اليها
لا يوجد اي من دبابات ابرامز
في الدول الاوروبيه
وجلها يتم الاحتفاظ بها لاغراض الدفاع
الوطني وعمليه
ايصالها الى اوكرانيا واعدادهم اعدادهم من
قبل استخدامها من قبل الاخرىين وتدريبهم
من حيث
كافه الامدادات الامر سوف يستغرق عده اشهر
انها مختلفه عن عمليه تزويد المانيا التي
لن تستهلك قدرا كبيرا من الوقت لكننا نحن
لا توجد لدينا قدره ايصالها بسرعه
وكما ذكرت في السابق
عند وصوله هذه الدبابات الى هناك نود ان
نضمن بانها سوف تصل الى الاشخاص الجاهزين
بحيث يكون هناك قوه اخرى امنيه تمتلك
التدريب الكافي هو لديها قطع الغيار التي
قد تحتاجها من اجل استخدامها لتكون اكثر
فعاليه على الارض
ما الذي يمكنه ان ترضعه ابره
تم الحديث اليوم بانهما من تاريخ قد تم
رزقه على وجه التحديد لارسالها
خطتكم بالنسبه
لدعم اوك اوكرانيا واود ان اعقب على سؤال
حول عدد الدبابات
الى 300 دبابه من الغرب هل هذا الرقم
واقعي برايكم ام هل هذا سوف يكون هو
المخطط في المستقبل اذا ما اخذ اذا ما
اثبتت اخرى انها قادره على استخدام هذه
المبادره
اننا نركز في الفتره الحاليه على هذا
البرنامج من اجل تامين الواحد 31 دبابات
ابره وضماني كافه التدريب المطلوب من اجل
تشغيل وصيانه تلك الدبابات وبناءا على
المحادثات التي اجرها الرئيس بوتن مع
شركائنا في الغرفه
على النقل ايضا مركبات
اخرى تستخدم خلال فتره قصيره من الزمن
نركز على الاعلان الذي طرحه الرئيس اليوم
قلتم ايضا ان الخطوه القادمه بالنسبه
لاكرانيا من اجل سوف تكون طلب صواريخ
طويله الامل
هناك محادثات مستمره الان تجري حول تعزيز
قدرات تعزيز قدراتي اوكرانيا ما هو الاطار
الزمني بالنسبه لتقديم
تلك
الاسلحه المتطوره ثانيا
حاول بقى هل لديكم اي مخاوف بشان الوقود
كيف سوف تتعاملون مع هذا الامر
انها دبابات تعمل بموجب بتربينات الوقود
وتستهلك قدرا كبيرا
[موسيقى]
الصحفي ساعود اذاكر بابرز ما قاله البيت
الابيض للعربيه بان بوتين يستخدم الشتاء
لاعاده تجميع صفوفه وشان هجوم جديد في
اوكرانيا وبن البيت بان الولايات المتحده
ارسلت الدبابات لاوكرانيا لتكون جاهزه
بحلول الربيع وايضا همم البيت الابيض
ارسلنا دبابات لاوكرانيا لتكون جاهزه
للدفاع عن نفسها بحلول الربيع طبعا
الاسلحه التي ارسلها سيكون هناك تدريب
عليها اذا كان هذا المؤتمر الصحفي الذي
عقد في البيت الابيض للحديث عن الدفعه
الدبابات التي اعلن عنها الرئيس
تزود بها الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا
بحربها مع روسيا
باخر اخبار التاسعه ارتفعت ثروه رجل
الاعمال الامريكيه الى ماسك بما يقرب من
11 مليار دولار منذ ان بدات محكمه مدنيه
امريكيه في سماع شهادته في قضيه بسبب
تغريده تعود عام 2018 والتي اشار فيها الى
خطته لشطب شركه تسلا من البورصه وتحويلها
الى شركه خاصه مع ضمان التموين
مليار دولار عام 2022 ما جعله الشخص
الوحيد الذي يفقد مبلغا بذات القيمه في
عام
لكن الان يبدو ان الامور قد تنقلب
ماسك يضيف احد عشر مليار دولار الى ثروته
في يومين فهل يستعيد لقبه الضائع كاغنى
رجل في العالم
[موسيقى]
قفزت ثروه ماسك الى اكثر من 145 مليار
دولار وهو اكبر مكسب في يومين منذ نوفمبر
الماضي
كده من التاسعه مشاهدينا مع العناوين
دبابات
في هجوم داخل قطار في المانيا وسلطات تعلن
اعتقال المنفذ
صراع قضائي يحدد التحقيق في انفجار مرفا
بيروت والبيطار للعربيه انا الوحيد
المعاني بالتحقيق
يعبر مذكراته بمكالمه هاتفيه منعنا حربا
نوويه بين الهند وباكستان عام 2019
مشاهدينا التاسعه انتهت لكن اخبار العربيه
مستمره كما كل الليله